Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge Dicke Bretter.
Ich bin Elina und ich bin heute hier zusammen mit Elisa. Hallo Elisa.
Hallo Elina.
Schön, dass wir mal so zu zweit in dieser Runde sind. Wir haben nämlich diesmal
keine Expertinnen eingeladen.
Konstanze ist diesmal auch nicht dabei.
Und wie in jeder Folge Dicke Bretter wollen wir euch heute auch wieder ein Policy-Thema
anhand von einem eher netzpolitischen Thema erklären.
Und es gibt eigentlich nichts, was gerade naheliegender ist,
nämlich das Thema Bundesministerien.
Wir bekommen nämlich jetzt endlich ein Digitalministerium. Darauf haben wir
alle gewartet, vielleicht auch nicht.
Darüber werden wir später nochmal genauer sprechen.
Definitiv.
In dieser Folge wollen wir mal, anders als sonst, ein Format ausprobieren und euch mitnehmen.
Ich würde sagen, auf einen wilden Ritt von Just Another Digital Strategie zu.
Alle Menschen und Organisationen und Verbände haben sehr klare Vorstellungen
davon, wie das Digitalministerium aussehen soll.
Und vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen Hintergrundwissen, was eigentlich ein Bundesministerium ist.
Bezeichnet das Bundesministerium für Digitales und Staatsmodernisierung, kurz BMDS.
Ich verwechsel das manchmal mit einer anderen Abkürzung.
Ich bin froh, dass ich nicht die Einzige bin,
der das so geht.
Ich glaube, da hat jemand aufgepasst in der Pressestelle und die Abkürzung wurde anders gewählt.
Bundesministerium sind grundsätzlich die höchsten Bundesbehörden Und zusammen
mit dem Bundeskanzler bilden Bundesministerinnen die Bundesregierung.
Und jedes Ministerium ist für einen bestimmten Bereich zuständig.
Und im Grundgesetz habe ich gelernt, weil ich nämlich auch dachte,
naja, das ergibt sich irgendwie logisch, was für Ministerien es gibt.
Ist es tatsächlich geregelt, dass es ein Finanzministerium geben muss,
ein Justizministerium und auch ein Verteidigungsministerium.
Und dann würde man denken, vielleicht ergibt sich der Rest so.
Es ist aber tatsächlich so, dass sich diese sogenannten Ressortzuschnitte,
also die Themen, für die ein Ministerium am Ende zuständig ist, sich ändern können.
Und das sehen wir jetzt auch gerade bei der aktuellen Regierungsbildung mit
dem Digitalministerium.
Und diese Ressortzuschnitte kommen zustande,
man findet sie initial meistens im Koalitionsvertrag, weil die Koalitionsparteien
da festlegen, wer welches Ministerium bekommt und um das festlegen zu können,
muss man logischerweise wissen, was für Ministerium es geben soll.
Und formal werden die Zuschnitte dann vom Bundeskanzler dann über den sogenannten
Organisationserlass festgelegt.
Das ist jetzt gerade passiert, wir nehmen am 23.
Mai auf, der Organisationserlass ist vom 6. Mai und dieser legt dann fest,
welche Ministerien es gibt, wie diese benannt werden.
Häufig werden Ministerien nämlich auch umbenannt und für welche Bereiche die
Ministerien konkret zuständig sind.
Und beim BMDS, also beim Digitalisierungsministerium, handelt es sich ja um eine Neugründung.
Und das heißt, da steht zum Beispiel auch in dem Organisationserlass,
welche Bereiche die Ministerien aus anderen Ministerien übernehmen,
beziehungsweise auch welche neuen Aufgaben es bekommt.
Das erstmal so zu dem ersten theoretischen Teil.
Ich fand, da wurde auch irgendwie viel zu wenig drüber geredet und trotz Politik-Leistungskurs
hatte ich auch relativ wenig Wissen darüber, wie genau das geregelt ist mit Ministerien.
Und jetzt können wir ja mal so ein bisschen darüber sprechen,
wie das mit dem Digitalministerium so zustande kommt und ich fand so,
Die Monate davor ist echt viel so durchs Internet gewamert von Menschen.
Also jeder Politiker, primär glaube ich Politiker, hatte irgendwie was dazu
zu sagen, wie so ein Ministerium für Digitales eigentlich aussehen sollte.
Leuchtturmprojekte waren auch wieder Stichwort Nummer eins. Was war denn so
die absurdeste oder interessanteste Meinung zum Digitalministerium,
die dir so über den Weg gelaufen ist, Elisa?
Ja, ich glaube, die ganz Abstrusen habe ich gar nicht gelesen,
weil mir da die Absender schon suspekt vorkamen.
Tatsächlich haben aber wirklich viele Pläne vorgelegt, haben das mal auf dem
Papier entworfen, welche Zuständigkeiten ein Digitalministerium im besten Fall haben sollte.
Und das ist ja auch total nachvollziehbar, denn so ein neu zu gründendes Haus
ist ja erstmal ein Moment der Möglichkeiten und zwar der Möglichkeiten Sachen
richtig gut zu machen oder sie halt auch komplett zu versemmeln und genau das
wollten glaube ich viele in ihrem Interesse in irgendeiner Form beeinflussen.
Und deswegen sind die Konzeptpapiere, die X-Punkte-Pläne, die es gibt,
also deren Zahl ist Legion.
Und ich habe eins rausgezogen, einfach nur, weil ich die Einleitung so schön
fand, weil es nochmal zeigt, wo wir mit Digitalisierung in diesem Land stehen.
Die Inhalte sind ansonsten gar nicht so verkehrt.
Das ist ein White Paper, digitale Transformation, ein Neun-Punkte-Plan für neue Zukunftslust.
Und die Zukunftslust steigt. Zukunftslust? Zukunftslust, ja.
Passt vielleicht zu dem Akronym, das wir so fälschlicherweise öfter verwendet.
Aber tatsächlich ist die erste Einleitung wirklich wunderbar.
Und zwar ist es ein historischer Rückgriff. Und ich zitiere,
Als vor über 200 Jahren der preußische Staatsmann von Hartenberg mit seinem
adeligen Blutsbruder von und zum Stein die preußischen Verwaltungsreformen auf den Weg brachten,
lag das Königreich buchstäblich am Boden.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob unser Königreich jetzt am Boden liegt oder was dieser
Rückschritt, ich weiß nicht, was genau dieser Rückgriff bewirken sollte,
aber offensichtlich sollte er Zukunftslust erwecken dadurch,
dass er nochmal aufgezeigt hat, wie viel wir zu tun haben, weil also offensichtlich
auch unsere ein bisschen preußisch angehauchte Digitalisierungszuständigkeit
am Boden liegt und da ist also wirklich viel zu tun.
Das fand ich dann doch ganz interessant. Wie war es denn bei dir?
Jetzt zurückblickend, also wir wissen ja noch nicht so viel,
wir haben ja noch nicht so viel erzählt, was mit dem Digitalministerium passieren wird,
aber neben diversen Verbänden und Organisationen hat auch McKinsey was dazu
zu sagen und das fand ich irgendwie ganz lustig,
weil Lilith spricht doch immer so von dieser Beratertreppe in der Verwaltungsdigitalisierung
und McKinsey wollte dem glaube ich mal zuvorkommen und er hat sieben Fallstricke
beim Aufbau von Digitalministerien und wie sie zu vermeiden,
sind, herausgegeben.
Das war allerdings auch schon im Februar, also relativ früh.
Und ja, da kamen dann so Gefahren auf.
Aber was ich natürlich sehr spannend finde, ist zum Beispiel Fallstrick Nummer zwei.
Neues Haus bauen, statt schnelle Ergebnisse zu liefern.
Vorgehensprinzip, was Sie vorschlagen, von Tag eins an Ergebnisse liefern.
Wow.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das das ist, was wir gerade auf LinkedIn sehen.
Die Besuche vom Digitalminister bei ganz vielen Projekten, ob das die Ergebnisse sind, die wir haben.
Dann fand ich auch sehr schön Ende-zu-Ende-Verantwortung als Lösungsstrategie.
Es ging so gut los.
Und natürlich Fallstrick Nummer sechs, Agile Washing.
Das ist auch, finde ich, ein sehr spannendes Wort. Also ich glaube,
was es meint, ist agile Strategien falsch in bestehende alte Unternehmensstrukturen versuchen anzuwenden.
Also wir machen jetzt alle ein Stand-up, aber sonst machen wir eigentlich nichts
Agiles, sonst machen wir Wasserfall, so ganz klassisch.
Auf jeden Fall als Lösungsvorschlag ist Startup-Kultur zu finden mit dem schönen Satz, ich zitiere,
um die Vorteile agiler Arbeitsweisen zu erschließen, sollte eine neue Organisation
flache Hierarchien schaffen und Abstimmungsformate für schnelle Entscheidungen
im Sprintrhythmus einführen.
Die klassische Mitzeichnung und Ressortabstimmung sind hingegen auf Ausnahmefälle zu beschränken.
Ich finde es spannend, zumal das natürlich nicht mit Regierungsarbeit in Einklang zu bringen ist.
Wir werden sehen, wie agil die CDU ist. Es bleibt spannend.
Da ist vielleicht ganz spannend, dass eine der Kandidatinnen,
die lange als potenzielle Ministerin gehandelt wurden, Christina Sinemus,
die das vorher quasi das gleiche Amt aber in Hessen inne hatte,
Die hat in einem Interview gesagt, als sie gefragt wurde, was waren so die ersten
großen Punkte, die du gelernt hast in deinem neuen Job.
Das war faktisch, ich kam aus der Wirtschaft und ich habe gelernt,
dass es in der Verwaltung und in der Politik mit gutem Grund viel mehr Absprachen
und Verbindlichkeiten braucht, als wir das aus der Wirtschaft so kennen.
Insofern glaube ich, hat sie da diese Forderung konkret schon eine ordentliche Absage erteilt.
Ja, also ich glaube genau, wir kommen später noch zu den Personalien,
aber wir haben es, finde ich, generell in der neuen Bundesregierung mit extrem
viel Personal zu tun, was wenig,
also unabhängig jetzt mal von Doro Bär und Herrn Dombrind,
wenig Regierungs- und Politikbetriebserfahrung hat in dem Sinne.
Und ich glaube schon, wenn man so mit Menschen, die im Bundestag schon lange
arbeiten oder auch Menschen, die im Bundestag neu anfangen, spricht,
ist so das Erste, was sie sagen, uns fehlt ganz, ganz viel Organisationswissen
und dadurch müssen wir uns erstmal erarbeiten.
Und ich meine, deswegen haben wir ja auch irgendwie so ein bisschen mit diesem Podcast angefangen.
Wir müssen uns erstmal erarbeiten, wie das eigentlich alles hinter den Kulissen
funktioniert und was ich tun muss und was ich nicht tun muss, damit ich vorankomme.
Also Herr Wildberger, hören Sie gut zu und schreiben Sie mit.
Gerne beraten wir sie auch weiter.
Naja, weiß ich nicht.
Gut, aber vielleicht ist das ein guter Einstieg zu Organisationswissen und Lernen.
Wie kommt das eigentlich mit diesem Digitalisierungsministerium?
Und die ganz große Frage, wie gründet man eigentlich ein Ministerium, Elisa?
Ja, wie gründet man ein Ministerium? Das Gute ist, dass wir da ein historisches
Beispiel haben und das ist das Ministerium für Umwelt, damals hieß es Umwelt,
Naturschutz und Reaktorsicherheit.
Und wie der Name schon sagt, wurde das 1986 direkt nach der Reaktorkatastrophe
von Tschernobyl gegründet, auch wirklich wenige Wochen später,
weil der politische Druck und auch der gesellschaftliche Druck so hoch war,
sich mit diesem Pulverfass offensichtlich auseinanderzusetzen.
Das heißt, da wurde ein Haus aus dem Boden gestampft und das gibt es ja immer
noch, natürlich, weil die Probleme ja auch nicht weniger geworden sind in dem Bereich.
Tatsächlich ist es aber sehr selten, dass neue Ministerien gegründet wurden.
Du hast es am Anfang schon gesagt, dass die Zuschnitte sich öfter mal ändern
und dass die eben in diesen Organisationserlassen abgebildet werden.
Das war zum Beispiel beim im weitesten Sinne Familienministerium sehr oft der
Fall, wo also immer noch ein weiteres Ressort rangegangen ist.
Das war am Anfang Familienfragen, dann ging es um Frauen, um Jugend,
um Senioren und das führt am Ende halt auch dazu, dass Schröder das damals berühmt
Gedöns genannt hat, Also das Ministerium für Gedöns, weil das wie so ein Sammelbecken war,
zeigt aber auch, dass neue Ministerien oder Ministerien, die sich im Zuschnitt
erweitern, historisch gesehen nicht den höchsten Respekt haben, würde ich denken.
Also es ist ja schon so, dass Ministerien durchaus auch in einem,
nicht Konkurrenzkampf, aber in einem Zuständigkeitsgerangel miteinander liegen
und das ist tatsächlich auch was, wo wir später vielleicht nochmal drauf gucken können,
was erwartet uns denn da jetzt durch diese Neuschaffung des Ministeriums,
wie verhält sich das zu den Strukturen, die es einfach schon gibt.
Genau und tatsächlich haben wir nicht nur auf Bundesebene ein Digitalministerium,
wir haben auch schon Parallelen auf Landesebene.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du dich damit mal schon auseinandergesetzt hast, Elina.
Ich komme aus Bayern und deswegen weiß ich, dass es in Bayern ein Digitalministerium gab oder gibt.
Und ihr wart die Ersten. Ihr wart die Ersten.
2018.
Ja, voll die Schnellzünder. Innovatoren. Genau, krasses Ding.
Das ausgerechnet Bayern, Laptop und Lederhosen. Ich glaube, der Spruch war da
schon über 20 Jahre alt und dann gab es endlich ein Digitalministerium.
Bits und Pretzels ist der Nachfolger, glaube ich.
Es wird noch besser. Ich habe nämlich nochmal geschaut, was so die letzten Dinge
waren, mit denen das bayerische Digitalministerium Schlagzeilen gemacht hat.
Und tatsächlich war das, dass der neue Digitalminister, der zu den freien Wählern
gehört, der will jetzt unbedingt ein Bayern-Emoji.
Irgendwie bei Unicode, ich weiß nicht, was da vorsprechen.
Aber das gibt es doch schon, oder? Also den Bierkrug gibt es schon und den Menschen den Leder.
Also die Lederhose gibt es, glaube ich, auch schon als Emoji.
Ja, aber da ist keine Bayernfahne dabei. Also ich glaube, die Idee ist,
ein Löwen, also das bayerische Wappentier, mit einer bayerischen Fahne zu verbinden
und dann da irgendwie reinzukriegen.
Also viel Erfolg bei der Navigation von Unicode.
Mal gucken, ob wir das dann eingeben können oder wollen.
Aber tatsächlich würde ich schon sagen, dass die Digitalministerien auf Landesebene
einen ähnlichen Zuschnitt hatten wie das, was wir jetzt auf Bundesebene sehen.
Und da kommen wir dann ja auch schon bald zu den Zuständigkeiten,
über die wir nochmal in die Tiefe gehen können.
Dass es da vor allem die Anknüpfung an die Digitalisierung von Verwaltungsleistungen ging.
Und das vielleicht auch erklärt, warum die Ministerien jetzt nicht Schlagzeilen
auf der ersten Seite gemacht haben.
Weil das halt ein dickes Brett ist. Deswegen reden wir ja heute auch drüber.
Aber es gab jetzt keine Einschläge, was so Fortschritte in Bayern angeht durch
die Schaffung des Digitalministeriums oder gibt es da irgendwie so ein Leuchtturmprojekt?
Also ich würde sagen aus meiner Außensicht von heute, dass da bestimmt auch
sinnvolle Arbeit gemacht wird, aber dass jetzt das nicht den ganzen Verwaltungsapparat
in Bayern maßgeblich revolutioniert hat, das ist nicht eingetreten.
Und das ist natürlich auch die Frage, was erwarten wir denn eigentlich von so
einem Digitalministerium?
Erwarten wir da die komplette Rundum-Erneuerung?
Ist das etwas, was wir uns erhoffen oder gibt es da nicht auch ein paar Punkte,
bei denen wir genau hingucken müssen, weil eine Rundum-Erneuerung halt auch
immer eine Möglichkeit der Erosion von Grundrechten im Digitalen darstellt?
Ja, und du hattest sie vorhin schon ganz kurz erwähnt.
Christina Sinemus war und ist auch immer noch die Digitalministerin in Hessen.
Hessen hat 2019 nachgezogen.
Nachmacher.
Ja, die Hessen wieder.
Und sie hat auch zu ihrem Antritt verkündigt, dass Hessen das heimliche Silicon
Valley Europas werden könnte. Da sehen wir auch irgendwie schon ganz klar, wie es hingeht.
Das Ministerium hieß früher Ministerium für Digitales und Entwicklung und jetzt
heißt das natürlich Ministerium für Digitales und Innovation.
Ach, allgemein nicht KI.
Ja, und alles, was du auch schon gesagt hast, trifft auf dieses Ministerium ebenfalls zu.
Sein Ziel ist digitales und Bürokratisierung. Es ging um Verwaltung,
es ging natürlich darum, Hessen zum Silicon Valley zu machen.
Ich habe so ein paar Artikel gelesen zu der ersten Pressekonferenz,
als das Ministerium neu gegründet wurde und da war die Kritik sehr groß,
dass das alles irgendwie nicht klar sei,
was es denn jetzt eigentlich machen sollte.
Und naja, es gab jetzt auch nichts, was herausgestochen ist.
Ich glaube, sie haben den deutschen PA-Preis gewonnen für ihre Aufklärungsarbeit oder so 2025.
Das war so das einzig Nennenswerte, was ich finden konnte. Also wie gesagt,
die Digitalministerin war mal im Gespräch oder es waberte so durch die Gegend,
dass sie es vielleicht sein könnte und das Bundesministerium übernommen hat.
Das ist jetzt aber tatsächlich nicht passiert.
Wäre vielleicht ganz gut gewesen, weil sie immerhin Organisationswissen hat.
Sie selber ist Biologin und keine Informatikerin, konnte ich raushören.
Genau und das war es eigentlich auch so mit digitalen Ministerien auf Länderebene.
Es ist eigentlich überraschend, dass es nicht mehr davon gibt oder vielleicht
auch nicht, ich weiß es nicht.
Da bin ich auch sehr gespannt, wie das dann in der Zusammenarbeit mit föderalen
Strukturen aussieht, wenn man keine anderen MinisterInnen hat in den einzelnen
Bundesländern, mit denen man sich koordinieren kann.
Das wird auch wieder so ein Querschnittsproblem werden.
Jetzt haben wir ganz viel wieder über ein bisschen lustige und spannende Themen gesprochen.
Vielleicht nochmal zurück zur Theorie, weil für alle, die sich das auch gefragt
haben, wie baut man eigentlich so ein Ministerium auf?
Vorweg laut der Süddeutsche Zeitung Digitalministerium Live-Ticker,
wie ich ihn getauft habe, arbeitet das Bundesdigitalisierungsministerium,
sage ich jetzt mal ganz platt,
nach wie vor mit Hochdruck an seinem Organigramm.
Aber wir haben schon ein paar Personalien
und das sind auch so die Grundsatzpersonalien, würde ich sagen.
Denn grundsätzlich bestehen das Ministerium natürlich aus einem Minister.
Da haben wir, ich spreche ihn immer falsch aus, aber er heißt Carsten Wilderberger, richtig?
Wildberger.
Wildberger, naja. Wild ist es auf jeden Fall. und Carsten Wildberger kommt aber
nicht aus dem Politik- oder Ministeriumsbetrieb, sondern ist ein Manager.
So, der war vorher bei Saturn Mediamarkt, hat da wohl wahrscheinlich auch mit
Digitalisierung und digitaler Transformation, heißt es ja immer so schön, zu tun gehabt,
hat aber mit Politik bis auf diesen sagenumwobenen Wirtschaftsrat der CDU,
der Wirtschaftsrat e.V., der ja nicht zur CDU gehört, ist ja ein eigener Verein,
das ist so sein Anknüpfungspunkt.
Dort hat er auch schon eine seiner ersten öffentlichen Auftritte gehabt,
kurz nach seiner Ernennung.
Genau, so sieht es grundsätzlich erstmal aus.
Und zusätzlich zu dem Minister, uns ist gerade hier ganz kurz unser Setup ausgegangen,
deswegen die kurze Verwirrung.
Zusätzlich zu dem Minister gibt es sogenannte Staatssekretäre und es gibt sowohl
parlamentarische Staatssekretäre als auch Staatssekretäre oder man nennt sie
auch Beamtete Staatssekretäre.
Und die parlamentarischen Staatssekretäre
müssen Mitglieder im Deutschen Bundestag sein und sollen den Minister bei der
Führung des Ministeriums vertreten können und sie können den Minister auch bei
Anhörungen und ähnlichen im Bundestag und im Bundesrat vertreten.
Und da sind auch schon zwei parlamentarische Staatssekretäre benannt worden.
Die sind beide aus der CDU. Das ist nicht weiter überraschend,
denn das Digitalministerium ist in der Hand der CDU.
Und da haben wir einmal Thomas Jatzombeck für den Bereich Digitalisierung.
Ich kannte Thomas Jatzombeck vorher nicht. Elisa, hast du schon mal...
Informationen zu Thomas J. Zombeck.
Auf alle Fälle ist er seit vielen Jahren ein Haushaltsname in der Politik,
aber natürlich in der Union und damit jetzt vielleicht innerhalb des politischen
Spektrums, das für die Zivilgesellschaft jetzt nicht so ultra enthusiastisch offen steht.
Der ist schon sehr lange seit 2009 mit MdB, also Mitglied des Bundestages und
war in dem Bereich also tatsächlich auch schon in der, wie soll ich sagen,
in der politischen Szene natürlich aktiv, aber war zum Beispiel auch im C-Netz,
also dem Netzpolitischen Verein der Unionsfraktionen.
Ja, ich vergesse immer, dass die einen eigenen Netzpolitischen Verein haben,
aber das ist ja… Spricht auch Bände. Wie würde mein Professor sagen,
intuitiv, dass sie einen haben.
Und der zweite parlamentarische Staatssekretär, den kenne ich dafür umso besser.
Das ist nämlich unser lieber, altbekannter, junger, dynamischer Philipp Amthor
für den Bereich, wie könnte es auch anders sein, Staatsmodernisierung und Bürokratieabbau.
Und naja, Philipp hat natürlich auch schon den ersten Schritt gemacht im Bereich
Bürokratieabbau, weil IFG findet er nicht so geil.
Und das macht natürlich ja auch immer jede Menge Mist, wenn da so komische Menschen
andauernd Nachfragen stellen.
Aber genau, also Transparenz ist nicht so sein Ding und das ist natürlich dann
auch ein bisschen fragwürdig,
ob ein Politiker, der für Intransparenz steht, beziehungsweise weniger Transparenz
gerne hätte im Staatsapparat, dafür geeignet ist,
eine Staatsmodernisierung voranzutreiben, die für einen transparenteren und
nachvollziehbaren Staat sorgt, glaube ich.
Ja, das zum Thema parlamentarische Staatssekretäre.
Und dann gibt es noch die sogenannten Beamtetenstaatssekretäre und die sind,
wie der Name schon sagt, verbeamtet.
Und das ist auch sozusagen das ranghöchste Beamtenamt, was man so innehaben
kann. Und es sind deswegen auch die ranghöchsten Beamten in einem Ministerium.
Und die haben jetzt nicht eigene Themenbereiche.
Und die neuen Staatssekretärinnen im Digitalministerium sind auch wieder ein
altbekannter, unser Bundes-CIO Markus Richter.
Den kennt man. Ich habe jetzt gerade keine Anekdote. Ich kenne viele Menschen,
die Anekdoten zu Markus Richter haben. Oh, ich habe eine. Du hast eine.
Absolut. Also Markus Richter, der ehemalige
Bundes-CIO in
der letzten Legislaturperiode, bleibt uns erhalten.
Und ich erinnere mich an die ersten Schlagzeilen, die ich über ihn gelesen hatte.
Und die waren im Zuge der Geflüchtetenwelle in so 2016, 17,
wahrscheinlich auch noch später, als er für das Bundesamt für Migration und
Flüchtlinge dort Technik eingeführt hat, die der Spracherkennung und vor allem
auch der Dialekterkennung galten.
Das Ziel war da Leute, die also beispielsweise, also quasi zu prüfen,
ob die Geschichten von Menschen plausibel sind, kommen sie wirklich aus der
Region, aus der sie angeben herzukommen.
Und das ist natürlich so eine Automatisierung von Asylanerkennung,
die für die einzelnen Betroffenen so gut wie kaum anfechtbar waren.
Also da wurde schon hochproblematische Technologie in einem extrem sensiblen Feld eingesetzt.
Er hat in dem Zuge auch mal kurz sinniert, dass das BAMF ja nun eine Sicherheitsbehörde sei.
Also so hat er damals seine Arbeit wohl verstanden. Da ging es also um Terrorabwehr
bei den Ärmsten der Armen.
Und mal gucken, was jetzt sein Agenda sein wird in diesem neuen Haus.
Ja, sympathisch macht uns Hoffnung für digitale Menschenrechte und ich glaube
auch sonst ist er nicht unbedingt auf gutem Fuße mit einigen Akteuren in der Zivilgesellschaft,
insbesondere Sicherheitsforscherin, die sich kritisch Modernisierungsprojekte anschauen,
um es so ganz diplomatisch zu sagen.
Und die zweite Staatssekretärin, derzeit noch designierte Staatssekretärin,
da sie noch nicht ihren Amtseid abgelegt hat, ist Luise Hölscher.
Genau, wir werden sehen, wie es weitergeht.
Und damit haben wir sozusagen auch wieder den Theorie-Teil geschafft.
Vielleicht noch eine ganz wichtige Sache, wenn ein neues Ministerium gegründet
wird, ist für Behörden natürlich auch immer ganz wichtig, wo sie sitzen werden.
Das Bundesministerium für Digitales, nenne ich es mal wieder,
wird in der englischen Straße einziehen, in ein Gebäude, oder ist es wahrscheinlich
schon teilweise eingezogen, In ein Gebäude, was vorher zum BMI gehörte und das
wird wahrscheinlich nach und nach passieren.
Denke ich häufig hat das ja auch einfach, bleiben Abteilungen,
die denen sowieso schon zugeordnet sind, ja auch erhalten und ziehen gar nicht
um, sondern bleiben dann in diesem Gebäude und die Türschilder werden dann entsprechend geendet.
Aber Abteilungen, die ihnen zugeordnet wurden, ist vielleicht ein gutes Stichwort.
Wie sehen eigentlich die Zuschnitte aus?
Ich habe ja am Anfang schon gesagt, es werden Bereiche aus anderen Ministerien
herausgenommen und dem digitalen Ministerium übergeholfen.
Und das natürlich auch passiert. Und darüber wollen wir jetzt auch mal sprechen,
weil die vielleicht auch überraschend sind.
Ja, was findet sich jetzt bei dem neuen Bundesministerium für Digitales und
Staatsmodernisierung?
Du hast recht, es hat sich tatsächlich ziemlich viel von A nach B bewegt,
aber halt auch nicht alles.
Also es sind Zuständigkeiten aus dem Bundeskanzleramt, nämlich die sogenannten
Grundsatzfragen der Digitalpolitik, macht vielleicht auch Sinn,
natürlich auch aus dem Bereich Inneres, wobei da spannenderweise nicht alles,
was so vielleicht sinnvollerweise auf dem Papier auch rübergewandert ist.
Also konkret natürlich digitale Verwaltung geht in das neue Haus,
aber was ausgeschlossen ist, ist das Pass- und Ausweiswesen und wer regelmäßig
Netzpolitik.org liest, der weiß das zur Genüge.
Wir haben gerade auf EU-Ebene und jetzt auch in der nationalen Umsetzung diverse
Vorhaben, die genau an diese Schnittstelle gehen.
Also die Digitalisierung von Identitäten, Identitätsdokumenten,
die dahinterstehen, Infrastrukturen.
Da tut sich ehrlich gesagt so eine Kluft auf in den Zuständigkeiten,
wo glaube ich nochmal spannend wird zu sehen, wer jetzt am Ende faktisch was umsetzt.
Hast du noch ein anderes Beispiel von Dingen, die sich verändert haben?
Ja, also ich glaube, so was aus dem Bundeskanzleramt gekommen ist,
ist alles so ein bisschen abstrakt, so strategische Vorausschau,
Verhaltenswissenschaften und bürgerzentrierte Politik.
Also das wäre so ein bisschen der Bereich auch digitale Zivilgesellschaft.
Grundsatzfragen Digitalpolitik hattest du, glaube ich, auch schon gesagt.
Aber ansonsten sind das nicht so überraschende Sachen.
Aus dem BMDV, also aus dem Bundesministerium für Verkehr, was ja vorher auch
Digitales mit gebündelt hat,
kommt Digital- und Datenpolitik, was ja immer so ein bisschen in diesen Bereich
Datennutzung fällt und digitale Infrastruktur.
Also da bleibt es halt einfach weiterhin spannend, was eigentlich mit dem Breitbandausbau ist.
Aber da Dorothee Bär ja jetzt anderweitig beschäftigt ist, kriegen wir vielleicht
doch Breitbandausbau statt Flugtaxis.
Nee, wir kriegen jetzt Raumfahrt statt Flugtaxis.
Ja, wahrscheinlich war das die Inspiration für Ihre neue Stelle.
Ich glaube, was ich nochmal spannend finde, ist, dass der Punkt,
unabhängig davon, dass es jetzt nicht überraschend ist, aus dem Wirtschafts-
und Energieministerium,
nämlich Datenverfügbarkeit, digitale Souveränität,
Investitionsprüfung und der Digitalgipfel.
Also dass das Digitalministerium jetzt den Digitalgipfel übersieht, relativ klar.
Datenverfügbarkeit, finde ich, ist irgendwie so ein spannender Punkt,
wo ich noch nicht so richtig, also wo ich glaube ich schon sehr genau weiß,
was die sich darunter vorstellen.
Aber wo ich dann sagen muss, wir hatten da im Vorfeld eben gerade ganz kurz
drüber gesprochen, zum Beispiel die elektronische Patientenakte verbleibt ja
im Gesundheitsministerium.
So sieht es derzeit aus. Genau.
Also das wird dann vielleicht auch nochmal so ein paar Ressortstreits geben
gegebenenfalls, was wahrscheinlich bei diesem Querschnittsthema Digitalisierung
nicht zu verhindern ist.
Aber Datenverfügbarkeit frage ich mich halt schon.
Und klar, das ist jetzt irgendwie ein Wording, das ist ein Themenbereich,
aber wenn wir über Staatsmodernisierung sprechen und auch so OZG und was da
alles im Vorfeld auch gewesen ist und dann der Punkt Datenverfügbarkeit wieder
da ist und Datennutzung ist auch irgendwie so ganz weit oben in der Liste,
dann wird es natürlich schwierig.
Und was einem natürlich auffällt, das hattest du ja vorhin auch,
also vorhin in unserem Vorgespräch ja auch schon gesagt, ist,
dass der Verbraucherschutz aus dem Justizministerium gar nicht rübergewandert
ist ins Digitalministerium, soweit wir das sehen können.
Genau, vielleicht dazu zwei Worte. Also in der letzten Legislatur war der Verbraucherschutz
beim BMU, deswegen hieß das auch BMUV, also Umwelt- und Verbraucherinnenschutz
und noch ein paar Dinge dazwischen.
Und jetzt wird das rückgängig gemacht im Vergleich zur Legislatur davor,
der letzten Merkel-Legislatur, kommt der Verbraucherschutz wieder in den Bereich
Justiz. Ich finde beides ehrlich gesagt nachvollziehbar.
Ich finde auch, dass Verbraucherschutz nah an der Rechtsgebung zu haben,
ist nicht verkehrt, wenn denn die, wie soll ich sagen, die Stoßrichtung des
Hauses allgemein quasi für Verbraucherinnen ist.
Aber da wird sich auf alle Fälle vielleicht auch ein Kompetenzgerangel ergeben,
wie du schon sagst, weil natürlich wir gerade im Digitalen eine ganze Menge
von Themen haben, wo VerbraucherInnen von schlechten Geschäftspraktiken negativ betroffen sind.
Und wenn wir dann einerseits ein extrem wirtschaftsfreundliches Digitalministerium
haben und auf der anderen Seite ein Justizministerium, das hoffentlich einen
wirkungsvollen Verbraucherinnenschutz im Digitalen umsetzen will,
dann haben wir da einen Zielkonflikt und wer die Battle, den Battle gewinnt, werden wir dann sehen.
Ja, und ich glaube, das spiegelt sich auch ganz schön wieder in dem letzten
Nachsatz, nachdem Sie diese ganzen Themenbereiche aus den anderen Ministerien
gezogen haben, heißt es weiter,
das Bundesministerium für Digitales und Staatsmodernisierung erhält ferner die
Zuständigkeit für einen Zustimmungsvorbehalt für alle wesentlichen IT-Ausgaben
der unmittelbaren Bundesverwaltung,
mit Ausnahme der Geschäftsbereiche des Bundesministeriums der Verteidigung und
der Sicherheit und Polizeiaufgaben im Geschäftsbereich des Bundesministeriums
des Inneren und Bundesnachrichtsendienstes sowie der Steuerverwaltung im Geschäftsbereich
des Bundesministeriums der Finanzen.
Das Nähere zum Zustimmungsverbehalt regelt eine Vereinbarung.
Das finde ich nämlich spannend, weil wenn wir irgendwie uns Steuerverwaltung,
also wenn ich an Staatsmodernisierung und Entbürokratisierung denke und das
auch in dieser Denkschule von wir müssen die Wirtschaft irgendwie entlasten denke,
dann wäre ja das Erste, wo man irgendwie ran wollen würde aus einer Perspektive Finanzen und Steuer.
Ja, also das ist aber jetzt natürlich irgendwie abstrakt geregelt,
aber da wird es bestimmt dann, glaube ich, auch nochmal spannend,
wie viel Abstimmung und Gerangel das dann tatsächlich braucht.
Und ich glaube, das wird, glaube ich, auch so die größte Problematik.
Du hast es vorhin schon kurz erwähnt, so dass neu gegründete Ministerien das
nicht besonders einfach haben und auch manchmal nicht besonders ernst genommen werden.
Die Idee von diesem Digitalministerium ist ja eigentlich, dass wir irgendwie
das alles bündeln und dass das dann auch irgendwie besser laufen wird.
Gerade sehe ich irgendwie sehr viel Gerangel auf uns zukommen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie deine Wahrnehmung ist.
Ja, ich gebe dir insofern recht, dass der Zuschnitt vielleicht doch nicht so
klar ist, wie es manchmal in den Medien wirkt.
Tatsächlich ist glaube ich aber der Jetzt-Zustand immer noch ein klarerer,
als wir während der Koalitionsverhandlungen so vermutet hatten.
Ich glaube, da ging das Ganze schon wieder sehr in eine Aufteilung und auch
so ein bisschen Besitzstandswahrung in den einzelnen Häusern,
was ja auch dazu geführt hat, dass das Digitale so überall verteilt ist und
zwar auf eine Art und Weise verteilt ist,
die am Ende der Umsetzung von Maßnahmen, die sinnvoll sind, nicht unbedingt dienlich ist.
Wir haben natürlich immer diese Grundsatzfrage in der Architektur,
ist denn Digitalisierung was, was zentralisiert betrachtet werden sollte oder
ist es was, was wie so ein Querlager, also durch die verschiedenen Bereiche
hindurch betrachtet werden sollte.
Ich glaube, da gibt es keine abschließende Antwort für.
Ich glaube, was wir aus unserer Vergangenheit sagen können, ist,
dass beide Ansätze sehr schlecht umgesetzt werden können.
Und die Frage ist jetzt eben, führt diese Zentralisierungsbewegung tatsächlich
zu einer Verbesserung des digitalen Standes in Deutschland?
Und ich glaube, das muss sich halt zeigen, es gibt zumindest mal eine Kompetenzbündelung,
aber wofür die jetzt genutzt wird, ist halt tatsächlich fraglich.
Du hast es ja gerade auch schon deutlich gemacht, bei den Personalien haben
wir Leute, die sehr, sehr wirtschaftsfreundlich sind.
Ich meine, was vielleicht ganz gut ist, ist, dass Wildberger eine Geschichte
hat in Telcos. Insofern ist ihm zumindest dieser Bereich nicht unbekannt.
Aber ja, trotzdem die Frage, was wollen die eigentlich bewegen und wohin geht die Reise?
Das definiert ja keine Struktur, sondern das definieren oder bestimmen am Ende
die Personen, die da an der Spitze liegen. Und ich glaube, das wird nochmal spannend.
Vielleicht noch eine letzte Ergänzung zu der Personalie Wildberger.
Du hast zu Recht gesagt, er wurde natürlich von der Union benannt und auch die
StaatssekretärInnen sind Union, unionsnah.
Und er hat aber tatsächlich bei seiner Ernennung, soweit ich weiß,
noch kein Parteibuch gehabt.
Das hat er dann irgendwie sich ganz kurz später geklickt oder ich weiß nicht,
ob das schon digital ging.
Oder ob er da irgendwie auf eine Stempelstube musste.
Ist er jetzt CDU-Mitglied?
Er ist jetzt CDU-Mitglied.
Ja. Ah, mein letzter Stand war nämlich, dass das gar nicht ist,
aber vielleicht habe ich das auch.
Gucken wir doch nochmal auf die tolle neue Seite mit dem offiziellen Siegel
des Bundes, so der Minister.
Genau, also er ist ja im Mai 2025 beigetreten.
Ja, seit Mai. Also er ist sozusagen mit Ernennung beigetreten, ja.
Kausalität oder Korrelation?
Das ist eine gute Frage, die wir nicht beantworten wollen.
Und die am Ende vielleicht auch gar nicht so wichtig ist. Also faktisch ist,
glaube ich, er steht inhaltlich schon aufgrund seiner Biografie dem Programm
der Union sehr nahe und wird das wahrscheinlich auch sehr, sehr gut umsetzen.
Ja und ich glaube, es stellt sich auch, also das ist die Frage,
die mir auch immer wieder gekommen ist, was sollte so ein Digitalministerium erstmal machen?
Und gibt es nicht vielleicht auch Themen, auf die es sich erstmal fokussieren
sollte und das ist natürlich dann immer dieses Thema Verwaltungsdigitalisierung,
was wir halt einfach nicht hinbekommen.
Da stellt sich ja dann auch immer so die nächste Frage, wie sieht eigentlich
gute Verwaltungsdigitalisierung aus und wie sieht eigentlich auch so gemeinwohlorientierte
Digitalisierung aus Und ich glaube,
das ist so das Thema, du meintest so, die sind alle schon so von der Wahrnehmung
total wirtschaftsnah oder auch vielleicht sogar wirtschaftsorientiert,
würde ich fast schon sagen, weil es geht irgendwie um Innovation.
Also manche Sachen, die ich so lese dazu und höre, sind gar nicht so weit weg
von diesen McKinsey-Vorschlägen, die wir da am Anfang besprochen haben.
Und die digitale Zivilgesellschaft, wo ich jetzt von meinem Gefühl sagen würde,
wenn ich, keine Ahnung, an so jemand wie Bianca Kassle denke zum Beispiel,
die extrem viel Wissen aufgebaut haben, auch internes Wissen über Verwaltungen.
Wenn man die nicht ernstzunehmend einbindet und Stand jetzt, so wie es aussieht,
ist da jetzt ja nicht der extreme Wille zu. Also es gibt zwei Staatssekretärinnen,
der eine macht irgendwie Staatsmodernisierung, der andere macht Digitalisierung,
was auch irgendwie, wo man sich so fragt, okay.
Wo ist der Unterschied?
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist, also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass so ein bisschen die
Idee ist, der eine macht eher so Regulierungsfragen des digitalen Raums, sage ich jetzt mal so.
Oder der Wirtschaft.
Der Wirtschaft, genau. Und der andere macht Digitalisierungsfragen,
im Zusammenhang mit dem Staat.
Aber da ist dann natürlich auch, wenn ich mir jetzt, ich habe mir jetzt mal
das Organigramm, was F5 vorgeschlagen hat, aufgemacht.
Und die schlagen zum Beispiel ja vor eine Staatssekretärin für internationale
Digitalpolitik, was total sinnvoll ist.
Gerade wenn wir auf EU-Ebene schauen, aber auch wenn wir schauen,
was sonst digitalpolitisch,
so Stichwort Internet Governance Forum und so weiter und so fort,
gerade passiert, dass das zu verankern und das auch einzeln zu verankern,
halte ich zum Beispiel für einen sehr sinnvollen Vorschlag, wo ich jetzt denken
würde, naja, wer macht es denn jetzt von den beiden?
Der, der Digitalisierung macht oder der, der Staatsmodernisierung macht? Weiß man nicht so genau.
Und die F5 hatte ja dann noch eine Staatssekretärin für die digitale Gesellschaft vorgeschlagen.
Das ist natürlich klar, dass das unter einer CDU-Regierung nicht passieren wird.
Aber ich glaube schon, dass es irgendwie eine Einbindung geben muss.
Klar gibt es dann irgendwie durch das BSI Einbindung von digitaler Zivilgesellschaft,
wo ich aber auch sagen muss, auch aus Erfahrung häufig,
ist das schön, da Denkanstöße geben zu können, aber tatsächlich geschriebene
Sachen, die dann durchgehen, sieht man extrem wenig.
Oder wie wäre dann da so deine Einschätzung zu diesem Zuschnitt der Staatssekretärinnen?
Also ich glaube, meine realistische Einschätzung ist, dass für Zivilgesellschaft
tatsächlich die Staatssekretärsebene ja schon immer und auch fast egal in welcher
politischen Konstellation schwer zu erreichen war.
Ich glaube, unsere Stärke ist, dass wir vertrauensvolle Kontakte auf die Arbeitsebene
aufgebaut haben und da ist ja auch nochmal ein spannender Punkt.
Also wir haben jetzt diese vier bis fünf Personalien ja mal benannt und natürlich
geben die die Richtung und die Agenda, die Schwerpunktsetzung vor.
Aber die große Frage ist ja jetzt, wer wird sich am Ende an diese Schreibtische
setzen und anfangen zu arbeiten.
Und nach jedem Organisationserlass haben wir immer wieder das gleiche Problem,
dass die neuen Ressorts und die Ministerien gucken müssen.
Stellen wir neue Leute ein, du hast gerade schon total richtig benannt,
dass dieses Organisationswissen total essentiell ist.
Zu wissen, wo kann ich eigentlich anrufen, zu wissen, mit wem muss ich absprechen,
überhaupt mal zu verstehen, wie diese ganzen über Jahrzehnte etablierten Prozesse funktionieren.
Das ist was, was am Ende eine Einheit dort handlungsfähig macht oder halt nicht.
So traurig das ist, ist das fast wichtiger, glaube ich, als die inhaltliche
Kompetenz. Und das ist jetzt eben die Frage, ziehen die ganz viele Digitalos
aus den anderen Ministerien ab? Auch das ist schon öfter vorgekommen.
Das heißt aber auch, dass die Kapazitäten und die Kompetenzen in anderen Häusern
weniger werden, bin ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so der Fan von.
Oder stellen die neue Leute ein, die jetzt Lust haben, sich in ein neues Ministerium
zu setzen und an diesem Strukturaufbau beteiligt zu sein, der lange,
wirklich lange dauern wird.
Also ich glaube, wir brauchen in den ersten zwölf Monaten nichts Großes von
einem neu geschaffenen Ministerium erwarten, weil einfach noch alles so unklar
ist, weil die nicht handlungsfähig sind, weil die erstmal intern gucken müssen,
dass sie den Laden zum Laufen bringen.
Und das ist tatsächlich ein großes Problem.
Gar nicht so sehr, wen können wir jetzt ansprechen, um konkret zu lobbyieren.
Ich glaube, dass der ganze Bereich jetzt erstmal so ein bisschen auf Eis liegt,
bis die sich intern ausgekäst haben, wohin denn die Reise gehen soll.
Und das ist natürlich was, was uns als Ziel wir Gesellschaft total in die Bredouille
bringt, weil wir ja die drängenden Probleme sehen. Und weil gleichzeitig aber
beispielsweise das Innenministerium oder auch auf EU-Ebene wir natürlich weiter
über Vorratsdatenspeicherung sprechen.
Also die Themen sind ja nicht weg, aber unsere Ansprechpartnerinnen sind so
ein bisschen schockgefrostet.
Die Themen sind nicht weg, sie sind nur woanders. Das ist, glaube ich, die Devise.
Und andererseits habe ich auch so das Gefühl gehabt, nachdem dieser Organisationserlass
rauskam, ich weiß nicht, ob es mir nur so vorkam, gab es dann doch eine Menge
Leute, die dann so direkt auf LinkedIn veröffentlicht hatten.
Ich arbeite jetzt übrigens im Digitalisierungsministerium.
Echt wer?
Ich weiß, also ich möchte jetzt keine Namen nennen.
Ich lese kein LinkedIn. Ah, okay.
Also es war so, also in meiner Timeline, jetzt oute ich mich,
dass ich hier von LinkedIn scrolle, aber tatsächlich, unter dieser CDU-Regierung
ist das sehr praktisch, weil das natürlich alles so wirtschaftsnahe Leute sind,
die halt sonst so Post schreiben.
I'm so humbled by...
Nein, ich habe mich von meiner Partnerin getrennt, was ich über Sales Management gelernt habe oder so.
Ist doch so. Also so LinkedIn-Posts, naja, nevertheless waren auf jeden Fall
sehr viele Leute in meiner Timeline und auch so kriegst du dann auch immer so
eine Menschen, die dein LinkedIn-Profil besucht hat.
Es waren auf jeden Fall erstaunlich viele, die angeblich beim Digitalisierungsministerium
arbeiten und denke ich mir halt schon, das wird ja jetzt nicht Wildberger gewesen
sein, der auf meinem LinkedIn-Profil war. Also ich glaube schon,
Glaube ich nicht.
Für so wichtig halte ich mich jetzt auch nicht. Der wäre eher vielleicht bei Sascha Lobo unterwegs.
Es war Philipp Amthor, der auf deinem Link auf die Runde gelangt hat.
Ja, natürlich. Hoffentlich nicht. Aber was ich eigentlich sagen wollte zu dem
Personal, was man noch bedenken sollte, es sind natürlich viele Digitalos nicht
wieder in den Bundestag gekommen.
Das heißt, es gibt natürlich fähiges Personal, was vorher für Bundestagsabgeordnete
gearbeitet hat, was jetzt,
wenn es nicht für irgendeinen anderen Abgeordneten jetzt arbeitet,
gegebenenfalls auch Ressourcen hätte, in einem digitalen Ministerium zu arbeiten.
Das ist immer die Frage, ob man das möchte und so.
Aber ich glaube, das ist auch noch eine Komponente, die man im Auge behalten sollte.
Naja, aber ich glaube genau, also die Themen sind nicht weg,
sie sind nur woanders. Das ist eine ganz gute Zusammenfassung.
Wahrscheinlich auch, dem wir häufiger begegnen werden im nächsten Jahr,
bis sich das Digitalministerium gefunden hat.
Ich meine, so Staatsbesuche und Besuche bei Projekten macht der Digitalminister
ja schon ganz fleißig, wie ich der Öffentlichkeitskommunikation ernehmen konnte.
Andere Menschen scrollen Instagram ich gucke mir an, was das
Digitalministerium macht ja, ich glaube es bleibt spannend ich hoffe wir konnten
euch ein bisschen näher bringen, was eigentlich so ein Ministerium ist,
was es genau macht, vielleicht da müssten wir uns dann vielleicht nochmal jemanden
einladen, der in einem Ministerium arbeitet und darüber sprechen darf
Und natürlich auch, was passiert denn mit den ganzen nachgeordneten Behörden
oder sonstigen Institutionen, die von diesem Wechsel jetzt betroffen sind?
Was passiert mit der FITCO?
Was ist eigentlich mit Zendos? Was ist die FITCO? Oh Gott, die FITCO ist ein Akronym.
Das ist die föderale IT-Kooperation.
Das heißt, die machen genau das, woran es halt immer hapert,
nämlich zu gucken, an welchen unterschiedlichen Stellen Digitalisierungsvorhaben angedockt sind.
Sondern zu gucken, wer muss eigentlich am Tisch sein, um dieses Problem anzugehen
oder eine bestimmte Maßnahme umzusetzen.
Und aber auch, was muss man technisch dafür eigentlich wissen.
Also quasi, die haben tatsächlich auch sehr viel technische Kompetenz,
die in den Ministerien ja tatsächlich oftmals fehlt.
Und ich glaube, das nochmal anzugucken, ach ja, und auch Zendes natürlich.
Also die Jutta Horstmann, die Chefin von Zendes,
also dem Zentrum für digitale Souveränität, wurde relativ kurz nach ihrer Benennung
gleich wieder entlassen, bevor das Digitalministerium als solches ins Gespräch
gebracht wurde, aber es quasi in Sack und Hüten war.
Und die Frage ist jetzt, was passiert da? Was passiert mit dem Digitalservice?
Also wir haben ja ganz viele Untereinheiten, sage ich mal, die losgelöst sind
aus dieser Ministeriumslogik, die da auch drin stecken.
Und da zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt noch mal genauer reinzugucken und zu schauen,
wie werden die eigentlich, ja auch im konstruktiven Sinne genutzt,
weil da wirklich viel Kompetenz vorhanden ist oder werden die abhängig gemacht
auf eine Art und Weise, die nicht mehr sinnvoll ist.
Das tatsächlich ist nochmal eine Betrachtung, die bestimmt etwas Zeit verdient
und der wir uns vielleicht mal an einer Mal widmen können.
Und wie immer, oder vielleicht habe ich das auch lange nicht mehr gesagt,
freuen wir uns natürlich auch über Vorschläge zu, also Themenvorschlägen,
was wir euch eigentlich einfach mal erklären sollen.
Wir sind Und dann stets bemüht euch, entsprechende Expertinnen zu suchen,
um solche Gespräche zu führen.
Wir bedanken uns ganz herzlich bei der Chaos Radio Crew, die wie immer unsere
Post-Production übernimmt und das überhaupt möglich macht, dass wir auf eure Ohren kommen.
Ihr könnt uns auch lesen bei Netzpolitik.org. Und Netzpolitik.org,
kann ich auch nochmal sagen, finde ich,
schreibt sehr gute Analysen, auch sehr zeitnah zu diesem ganzen Thema Digitalministerium.
Also da gibt es einige Artikel, die auf jeden Fall lesenswert sind zu diesem Thema.
Und damit sage ich vielen Dank, Elisa.
Vielen Dank, Elina.
Ich freue mich auf das nächste Mal. dann vielleicht wieder in Kombination mit Konstanze.
Oder vielleicht auch mit einer externen Gästin. Also wenn ihr Vorschläge habt,
wen wir einladen sollten, let us know.
Genau. Wenn ihr vielleicht selber eine Expertin zu einem Thema seid,
zum Beispiel Verwaltungsdigitalisierung oder im hessischen Digitalministerium
sitzt und erklären könnt, wie der Silicon Valley Progress aussieht,
dann freuen wir uns natürlich auch über Zuschriften.
Und damit sagen wir Tschüss, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Passt auf euch auf und scrollt nicht so viel bei LinkedIn.